previously our craziest combos in tekken
tournaments oh
[Music]
[Music]
as well
we're still looking for more tournament
videos especially in season 4 of tekken
7. expect that there will still be a mix
of tekken tag 2 like the first one so
make sure to comment your suggestions
below in order for us to continue with
this series
once again my name is drew and here is
another top 10 craziest combos in tekken
tournaments brought to you by ochoto tv
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one more time but look at that
one more round for ak to reset the
entire grand line
he won one round in the first game i
think oh my god
actually made me spit in real life right
there
oh
zero
[Music]
look at the road
there you go
yes
[Music]
[Music]
stop it look at the damage
not like this
and
[Music]
kick out
[Applause]
hit wall rising three
break the wall there you're forcing all
kinds of errors right now
damage wall-to-wall facebook
and he's so dominant with the taunt oh
and there's the camera he returns the
favor
jimmy now
forcing knees
back one yeah block oh encounters
[Music]
we go the whole stage right now
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
doesn't seem like he has much
what the [ __ ] jesus christ
oh my somebody hit that holy [ __ ] that
was sick
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
[Music]
wow oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
for many years and really adding that
this article you got to remember me
is the one that really popularized the
use of the tongue and he was able to
utilize it such a way that it becomes a
threat you have to be careful on how you
get up
wow the full combo everything perfectly
this time it still gets into i've never
seen that before and jdcr keeps tech
rolling and this is what you get against
the player as good as me
testing him you know uh he's gonna
definitely answer those
thanks for watching and be sure to
subscribe
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
she
[Music]